david katar ist besorgt schon wieder
haben ihn bauern aus dem norden des
landes truppenbewegungen der russen
gemeldet er ist unterwegs in dieser
region wie fast jede woche mit
hilfslieferungen für die familien in den
dörfern
diese familienleben unter russischer
bedrohungen
und in ständiger angst das land von den
russen gesetzt wird
weil ihr zuhause ein ziel für die es
kann jeden moment passieren und wir
müssen diese familien unterstützen
david katz arava fährt an die grenze zu
südossetien obwohl es eigentlich keine
richtige grenze ist
2008 haben die russen die provinz in
georgien hinter diesen dörfern nach
einem kurzen brutalen krieg kopiert und
besetzen das land
die menschen in den dörfern freuen sich
über den besuch von david und seinem
team
ich bin so froh ihn zu sehen dass er
gesund ist erst wie ein mitglied meiner
familie
[Musik]
alle werden geherzt auch nastia und
boris zwei russische journalist innen
die aus der heimat geflohen sind und in
georgien für die hilfsorganisation
arbeiten
nudeln reis und t das team bringt
regelmäßig spenden aus der hauptstadt
das lindert die not hier etwas der staat
zahlt keine rente für die bauern in
georgien sie leben sonst von dem aus der
hof ihnen gibt
[Gelächter]
jeder gemeinsam im moment wird
festgehalten
[Musik]
ich werde von der regierung nicht
unterstützt komme keine rente daher ist
es für mich so wichtig von der
hilfsorganisation von david hilfe zu
bekommen
fire river will uns ihr haus zeigen vor
einigen wochen hat der regen alles
zerstört
die decke ist undicht und auch nebenan
im schlafzimmer alles verschimmelt
[Musik]
staatliche hilfe fehlanzeige
wir fahren weiter auf die hügel der
georgischen landschaft irgendwo dahinten
liegen russische militärstützpunkte
david und sein team beobachten jede
bewegung fürchten um weitere russische
landnahme
bauer grundkapitals wie die hat seine
tiere hier fürchtet die russischen
soldaten denen er manchmal unfreiwillig
begegnet
wenn wir sie sehen hauen wir ab
natürlich ist es gefährlich wenn sie von
dort kommen wer wird sie aufhalten die
hirten sind ja auch hier
und tagsüber kommt dass viele hierher
die bauern hier fürchten die russen sie
nennen die region zone der angst die
männer der hilfsorganisation wollen neue
drohnen aufnahmen machen denn immer
wieder ziehen die russen den
stacheldraht und die grenzbefestigungen
neu immer tiefer ins georgische tiefland
hinein seit jahren dokumentiert kacar
aber diese grenz bewegungen die bauern
in der region sind wichtige zeugen doch
heute ist es zu windig die drohne fliegt
mich richtig
wenn putin in der ukraine gewinnt kann
ihn niemand stoppen
dann wird er seine aggressionen gegen
andere länder richten nicht nur gegen
georgien gegen ganz osteuropa
denn wir sehen dass putin seinen
einfluss vergrößern wird
und die alte sowjetunion wieder
herstellen
wir alle müssen ihn also stoppen
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter zu georgiens
berühmtester großmutter in dem kleinen
dorf qualität weil javani spiele seit
elf jahren hinter stacheldraht eines
nachts haben die russen ihren bauernhof
einfach eingezäunt seitdem ist sie so
etwas wie eine ikone des georgischen
widerstands jeder staatsgast wird an
diesem stacheldraht geführt
[Musik]
oma maria ist mittlerweile 88 jahre alt
auch sie nimmt die spenden gerne
entgegen
vielen dank
ein teil ihrer familie lebt auf der
anderen seite des zauns doch immer
wahljahr will nicht weichen
david katz arava erzählt immer wieder
gern die geschichte von oma wally und
ihrem mann
sie ist so etwas wie ein symbol des
widerstands
die sie der russischen besatzung und die
stirn
wir russen terrorisieren sie die ganze
zeit
als vor acht oder neun jahren der mann
von oma war ja noch lebte haben die
russen geschlagen und wollten dieses
stück land haben
und als der staat hat er zu seiner frau
gesagt
dass dieses haus nicht
denn wenn du gehst werden die russen
alles besetzen
[Musik]
ich bedauere so was hier passiert
und alles was ich will ist den menschen
hier zu helfen die in solch einer
situation sind
lebensmittel für eine alte dame
widerstand hinter stacheldraht
erbe eines ungelösten konflikts im
sommer 2008 brachen kämpfe zwischen
georgischen einheiten und südossetien
aus die provinz wollte sich von georgien
loslösen es gab hier immer schon
separatistische kräfte
russische panzer rückten dann in
südossetien ein besetzten das land
innerhalb von fünf tagen hatten sie die
region unter kontrolle über 800 menschen
starben tausende wurden verletzt
das land am fuße des kaukasus ist
aufgewühlt jede woche demonstrationen in
der hauptstadt vor allem die jungen
fürchten um ihre zukunft haben angst vor
russischen imperialismus und putins
aggression viele hier werfen der
regierung einen kuschelkurs mit russland
vor im parlament in tiflis sitzen einige
die die sanktionen gegen putin nicht
unterstützen
georgien war eines der ersten sowjet
länder die sich zum westen geöffnet
haben das kleine land wollte neue
partner hat einen schwierigen weg zur
demokratie hinter sich
auch irina und ihre freundin anna
treffen sich hier jede woche immer
abends voller hoffnung
viele der demonstranten fordern den
rücktritt der regierung und den weg nach
europa
[Applaus]
ich bin heute hier weil ich freiheit
will als allererstes
wir wollen der welt sagen dass wir zu
europa gehören
wir brauchen europa zur
weiterentwicklung und für ein gutes
leben
wir sind verabredet in einem
animationsstudio mitten in tiflis hier
entstehen comics und trickfilme viel
raum für kreativität
irina ist hier managerin sie orientiert
sich stark nach europa
wenn wir in der eu wären dann hätten wir
viele möglichkeiten
in meinem bereich heißt das wenn man
einen animationsfilm macht braucht man
nicht nur die finanzierung sondern auch
die ausbildung dazu
in europa könnten wir uns da wirklich
weiterentwickeln
viele hier haben in europa und den usa
studiert wollen aber in georgien etwas
aufbauen auch wenn die bedingungen hier
schwieriger sind wie etwa partner für
die projekte zu finden und geld für die
filme aufzutreiben
unsere tür ist offen zur europäischen
union und wenn die geschlossen wäre
wären wir allein mit dem feind wir haben
nicht genug kraft um in einem krieg
gegen russland zu bestehen weil wir ein
so kleines land sind
vor einigen wochen hat das land einen
antrag auf eu mitgliedschaft gestellt
aus angst vor russische aggression die
eu-kommission hat lediglich eine
aussicht auf eine europäische
perspektive gegeben das land müsse sich
weiter reformieren dann erst sei ein
kandidatenstatus möglich die studenten
hoffen trotzdem dass es schnell geht mit
der mitgliedschaft
sonst wären wir sozusagen zurück im
schlamm um bildlich zu sprechen
dann könnte sich die gesellschaft nicht
mehr entwickeln sondern in einer art
sowjets status zurückfahren
und georgien war ja eines der ersten
länder das sich aus der sowjetunion
gelöst hat und das hinter sich gelassen
hat
wir wollen weiter in die zukunft blicken
und nicht zurück
wir haben überraschend kurzfristig einen
interview termin mit der
staatspräsidentin bekommen
pressekonferenz im präsidentenpalast
salome surabischwili erklärt der
versammelten presse die entscheidung der
eu kommission
die regierung müsse weitere
anstrengungen in sachen justizreform und
pressefreiheit unternehmen auch sie
sieht einzig im westen eine zukunft für
ihr land
georgien hat gelernt mit der gefahr
durch russland umzugehen die besetzten
gebiete eingeschlossen und wir haben
immer unseren wunsch ausgedrückt nach
europäischer integration und
mitgliedschaft in der nato
das ist sehr wichtig das heißt wir sind
widerstandsfähig und niemand kann den
wandel aufhalten den das georgische volk
will
[Musik]
georgische aktivisten erzählen dass die
russen die grenzen in den konfliktzonen
dauernd bewegen was sagen sie dazu
das machen sie die ganze zeit sie
verschieben sie manchmal nur ein paar
hundert meter hin und her ich denke das
ist eine ganz klare strategie um die
ganze zeit spannung zu erzeugen und
druck auf uns auszuüben
das ist schon seit 2008 um druck auf die
dörfer direkt an der besetzung grenze
auszuüben und auf die behörden denn man
weiß nie wie man reagieren soll
aber dieses katz-und-maus-spiel sind wir
gewohnt und das wird uns und unser ziel
nicht verändern
welche chancen sie in die georgier in
einer mitgliedschaft
die meisten georgier sind viel nach
europa gereist dank der visafreiheit und
viele wissen genau was sie wollen für
sich und ihre kinder
und ein klares signal ist auch dass
viele studenten in europa oder in den
usa studieren die meisten in europa und
kaum jemand in russland
und viele sind ausgewandert nach europa
in den letzten jahren
georgien galt jahrzehntelang als
vorzeigeland beim wandel von einer
sowjet republik in eine demokratie
doch die eu hat hausaufgaben aufgegeben
georgen müsse sich weiter reformieren
sechs monate brüssel dem land zeit
gegeben um die forderungen für einen eu
beitritt zu erfüllen dann wolle man das
in brüssel noch einmal prüfen
laut umfragen sind 88 prozent der
georgier für eine europäische annäherung
vor allem die jungen
wir sind verabredet mit dem chef der eu
beobachtermission in tiflis
seit 2008 ist die eu hier mit rund 200
mitarbeitern
sie beobachten die lage an den
besatzungen
sie sagen dass unsere arbeit wichtiger
ist als jemals zuvor
angesichts der aggression russlands
gegenüber der ukraine und diesen
brutalen krieg in der ukraine
also unsere rolle hier als
stabilitätsfaktor in georgien und auch
als frühwarn stelle für anzeichen der
die stabilisation das ist sehr wichtig
und so haben wir das hier auch
wahrgenommen wir haben umfragen über
unsere arbeit hier gemacht und die
bevölkerung hier schätzt unsere
kontinuierliche und sichtbare präsenz
24 stunden am tag sieben tage die woche
und wir werden unsere patrouillen
weiterführen für die stabilität in
georgien
die frauen und männer fahren regelmäßig
an die besatzungs linien von abchasien
und südossetien sprechen mit den
bewohnern der dörfer und bewachen die
einhaltung des waffenstillstands und sie
kontrollieren ob die russen die linien
im land weiter verschieben
[Musik]